l'annoncé a toujours une place
particulière dans laquelle passe de
coeur j'ai proposé
on les emmène que deux assemblées
départementales scène jumelage officiel
entre les deux pôles et il est rare
qu'on prend à aimer partager
l'expérience aux collégiens de salut il
considère partement de l'union
demoiselle faisant un peu les idées ici
breuil et jeunes de l'année et je crois
que c'est on travaille ensemble en se
parlant en échangeant en respectant les
cultures et les traditions et l'histoire
est allé jaune que ce monde promesse est
dans le c'est un très grand plaisir
trois jours de commémoration ou qui sont
j'en suis sûr franchement de valmy
journal ici merci votre attention
ils savaient qu'ils avaient tous quitté
leur maison de famille le secteur
village
je ne savais pas où il allait il ne
savait pas où les arrivées
ils sont arrivés ici dans cette can am
les murs et j'apprends et porte pourrait
en parler avec tout ce qui peut
représenter comme d'un personnel
familial et long terme seulement certes
ils ont été hébergés dans une ancienne
prison mais ils ont été
ils ont été pris en charge
ils ont été
la nati contre nous de la tyrannie et
ensanglanté
semblant
[Musique]
sanaa il combat
ici
marchons marchons
[Musique]
si l'on mangé ma mie de pain internet et
le téléphone et le minitel dessus la
prise c'est tout ce que j'ai oublié ma
victoire je vais vous raconter une
histoire mais plus est bel et bien finie
en moselle au pays
si en france la barre mais ses mots
bon on va les gîtes ou les bretelles
jouët comme bon lui car si les au niveau
de la rue parce qu'on l'a reconstitué à
peut pas être telle qu'elle est présente
avec eux la jeune fille qui présentera
un document l'allemand vous qui fait un
contrôle du papier voilà alors a
patiemment expliqué en fait c'est un
montage a été fait par jeunes filles et
l'allemand ce parce que les japonais
sont
et cela sa cousine qui a pris la photo
des numériques son propre appareil photo
ce que tu est strictement interdite on a
des cas d'arrestation de gens sont ici
mois de prison pour avoir fait des
photos avoir accepté avec un appareil
photo et français donc c'était interdit
et c'est l'abbé le showdown autorisée
[Musique]
peut-être que vous avez mis
effectivement là partout et je vous en
remercie
donc merci merci à bruno et à son équipe
à l'ensemble des élus les doigts de
cette initiative et et c'est vrai que le
président weiten l'a suivi avec avec
plaisir et je pense que c'est d'autant
plus important pour nous ça a permis de
d'impliquer un certain nombre d'élus
départementaux notamment mosellan qui
n'ont pas forcément été confronté par
cette évacuation
je les en remercie doublement d'être là
avec nous depuis trois jours parce
qu'ils ont beaucoup appris cette
histoire il la connaissait pas ce qu'on
connaît tous impôts d'histoire de la
moselle mais qu'on n'y est pas
nécessairement confronté au codir et je
vais j'apprécie d'autant plus et je
pense que c'est important je vous offrir
cette plainte en en reconnaissance en
d'une amitié et en réitérant ce mode de
cinglé que j'ai dit que j'ai répété je
veux continuer avec bt personnellement
impressionné par la menace que tiennent
à votre bureau
or les mosellanes des mosellans que vous
avez un pays que celui où vont les aider
on accueilli et je crois que l'histoire
est encore plus forte ici qu'elle me
laisse me faisais parce qu'en moselle on
a besoin
alors vous avez besoin ici de nous là
m'a demandé de nous la faire vivre au
quotidien et plus ou ne la fait vivre
plus on s'est dit on bien nous aussi
on a tous essayé comme comme tu l'as dit
peter monsieur le maire on a tous à un
moment ou un autre dans un coin mois se
retournant essuyé une larme
on est prêt à le faire je sais tu es
c'est important de le faire en moselle
une journée de l'évacuation est déposée
l'année des mosellans parce que notre
objectif maintenant c'est celui de
transmettre cette histoire ses émotions
à nos enfants et en repartant dit si je
me dis je vais reprendre une phrase de
saint-exupéry qui disais c'est de ta
bière et orange réalité voilà le travail
était encore à toutes et à tous et merci
vive la vie vive la moselle et je le dis
avec beaucoup de plaisir
il est la france